we'll talk about cyber security in
interesting ways but there's a lot of
clever people
trying to do clever things to earn
not even just to break into the system
but to earn an edge of some kind in the
system
how do you uh how do you stay one step
ahead there's no silver bullet there's a
bunch of lead bullets right so it's it's
like
you know one thing we do is we just have
good test suites right so you're testing
every piece of code that goes out that's
like just common good best practice but
it's particularly important in financial
services
another thing we do is we hire third
party firms to try to audit this stuff
and break in another one we do is we
have a bug bounty program
so
we basically pay white hat hackers to
find this stuff before the black hats do
and um
we've paid out lots of good bug bounties
so
you know
try all the above and occasionally you
don't get it right you lose some money
and then you fix it and you keep going
so
yeah let's talk about cyber security a
little bit more yeah you mentioned using
stalling bank accounts yeah so that's
another one that's another interesting
one how do you protect against that
okay so fraud prevention
yeah is a big topic so one of the
there's a lot of things people do but
one of the things they do is that
you use machine learning right so you
look at
protector attack to protect against it
so
um what you want to do is kind of build
up a labeled data set of
all the different people who have turned
out to be fraudulent and good good
actors and hopefully collect as much
data as you can and then you'll you know
you might feed hundreds or thousands of
these factors into your machine learning
model and they'll come back with a risk
score
so you know an example of like the kinds
of factors people create or put in there
you know obviously i don't want to
disclose too many of them because it's
it's it's a cat and mouse game but just
kind of i don't know relatively
well-known stuff might be
um
you know you have device fingerprints
right so like what kind of device are
you on and what fonts do you have
installed a lot of people who are
farming lots of these accounts they're
using emulators and like virtual
machines and stuff they're not like you
know an average person on that device um
and then you'll see sometimes like
one of my favorite metrics we track for
for this was called like improbable
travel velocity so we would we're
tracking people's ips right and you
might see someone um
who was one day in austin texas and then
like an hour later they were in london
or something it's like well that's very
improbable i mean sometimes people are
using vpns so you got to be careful with
that because like there's legitimate
people who use vpns too but
um
if it's not possible for them we've
gotten on a plane and gotten there that
quickly then that's usually they're like
spoofing a device or ip sometimes those
are interesting factors but yeah if you
feed enough of these in um
you will oh the another fun one is like
you know real users will type their
credit card like one number at a time
yeah scammers have a list of them and
they'll just paste in a whole a whole
number
um so you can look at like the the
number of milliseconds between
keystrokes like there's all kinds of
stuff people have come up with you for
travel velocity you could probably
incorporate vpns too because there's
probably
a uh travel velocity for vpn switching
too
that's human-like like if you're using
legitimately vpn for something else yeah
um that that might be there's like
legitimate uses too actually you know i
feel embarrassed that i don't know this
probably should but the i'm not a robot
capture thing capture thing yeah so that
probably works in the same way like how
do you move your mouse maybe or how the
dynamics of the clicking totally but how
does that even work that well then and
why can't it be fake i need to look into
this because it's it's such a trivial
captcha it feels like should be very
crackable and yet a lot of
high security places use that yeah it's
really interesting it's another cat and
mouse game so i think they've yeah but
it's using a lot of similar signals like
mouse movements um keystrokes and then
obviously all the stuff that comes over
the the wire with your browser so like
what operating system what fonts you
know what headers are being sent over
and yeah um there's actually there's an
old website a camera was called it was
kind of like panopticlick or panopticon
or something but it basically was like a
proof of concept site that
um they would just show you all the data
that was kind of getting sent over with
your
your request and like
say that there's only one person in the
world who has this exact set of data
it's you and so it's almost like um
a work around a clever workaround to
track somebody
um make identify a unique person even if
like there wasn't a cookie involved or
something yeah this is a fascinating
world where you can't see anybody here
in the dark and yet you have a lot of
signal and you have to figure out who's
the real person who's not who's a robot
who's not
you